ganz eindeutig ja
es wird wahrscheinlich immer noch
menschen geben die ernsthaft glauben
dass die afd eine akzeptable heimat für
bürgerliche konservative sei sie mögen
einmal darüber nachdenken warum
professor look und hans olaf henkel
fluchtartig das lokal verlassen haben
nachdem sie gesehen haben wer sich dabei
der afd breitgemacht hat es mag auch
heute noch mitglieder bei der afg geben
die sagen also mit rechtsradikalismus
mit extremismus mit nationalismus
antisemitismus wollen wir nichts zu tun
haben aber sie geben denen in der afg
deckung die genau mit dieser politischen
motivation dort arbeiten der fall
kalbitz ist einfach es gibt viele
kalbitzer in der kfd und interessant ist
ja es geht ja um die frage ob er falsche
angaben gemacht habe hat beim eintritt
in die afg offensichtlich stört sich die
führung an der hfg überhaupt nicht an
dessen politische agenda an dem was er
politisch vertritt ob das vereinbar ist
wenn mit den zielen der afg damit
beschäftigen sie die sich gar nicht und
sagen der richtigerweise auf die 75
entscheidung hingewiesen
das ist eine ganz knappe entscheidung
also offensichtlich gibt es starken
rückhalt dass die afg unbedingt kalbitz
braucht herr gesehen ich fand das
erschreckendste dass helgoland und
verweise die chefinnen und chefs der afg
bundestag sind das giga überzogen waren
albig soll in der afc bleiben das zeigt
das wovon boss nach recht hat es gibt
starken rückhalt für ihn und die afg ist
ein sammelbecken von auch für
rechtsradikale und rechtsextremisten das
ist jetzt nicht besonders neu er hätte
beispielsweise ist ja einer der
sozusagen populärsten repräsentanten
populären anführungsstrichen der
bekanntesten repräsentanten der ist ein
offen bekennender rechtsradikaler und
kann
und solche leute fühlen sich in der afg
offensichtlich wohl und bis hinauf in
die spitze der bundestagsfraktion der
ard fühlt man sich offensichtlich mit
solchen leuten wohl
ich kann nur sagen die verfolgen einen
kurs der weit weg ist von dem was für
einen demokratischen spektrum für
akzeptabel halten